ما ان رفعت السلطات قيود مكافحه الوباء
حتى حزمه كثير من الصينيين امتعتهم للسفر
انتظرت ويشين كغيرها من المواطنين فرصه
للتمتع باجازه خارج البلاد
وبعد ثلاثه اعوام ظلت فيها تخشى متطلبات
السفر من فحوصات في المطارات وحجر صحيا
لفتره طويله عند العوده تبدو اليوم سعيده
بزوال كل تلك العقبات وها هي في طريقها
الى قضائه اجازه هي الاولى منذ بدا
الجائحه
بسعاده كبيره كنت احس باحساس ذاته عندما
سافرت الى الخارج لاول مره وحتى ما غادرته
للمنزل هذا الصباح لم اكن اصدق انني مسافر
وماليزيا هي اكثر الاماكن التي يقصدها
الصينيون بعد رفع القيود
علاوه على المواقع السياحيه داخل البلاد
التي خلت من الزوار طيله مده سريان القيود
الصحيه الصارمه ما وضع تحديات امام قطاع
السياحه الصيني الجزء المهم من قطاع
الخدمه الذي يمثل نصف الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للصين على مدى ثلاثه اعوام منذ
بدء الجائحه حاله قيود السفر الصارمه
واسعار التذاكر المرتفعه بين الصينيين
وبين السفر خارج البلاد وما ان رفعت
القيود حتى انتعشت مبيعات وشركات السياحه
والسفر الصينيه
الارقام تشير الى تضاع في حجوزات الرحلات
الجويه في الايام الاولى بعد رفع القيود
باكثر من مرتين ونصف
ورغم ذلك لا يزال لدى السياح الصينيين بعض
الهواتف
التفاعلي لموقعنا الرسمي لكن السياحه
قلقون بشان سياسات الوقايه من الوباء في
مختلف البلدان والدول التي لا يسمح
لسياحنا بدخولها
على المسافرين القادمين من الصين
وتبعتها دول اخرى بينها الولايات المتحده
ودول اوربيه
سياسيه ففي عام 2019 انفق نحو 170 مليون
سائح صينيه اكثر من 200 مليار دولار في
تلك الدول وغيرها ليكون السياح الصينيون
مصدرا مهما لتنشيط حركه السياحه فيها
ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره بهجين